Google's been involved in making phones
for years but the Nexus devices were
always for developers not for people but
this the Google pixel is meant for
everyone it's meant to compete with the
iPhone the pixel is the first phone that
Google has been fully in charge of
making and it has a bunch of interesting
features first of all it's meant to be a
really high-end design it has this
aluminum back with the glass panel at
the top which to be honest I don't
really like but your mileage might vary
there's a fingerprint reader on the back
there's a camera on the back that is
supposed to be the best smartphone
camera ever made it's hard to test here
but we'll see in general it's a really
simple clean high-end phone the way that
the iPhone is a high-end phone it's 649
dollars also the same price as the
iPhone and if you're getting the theme
here the goal is to compete at the
high-end but the big thing Google has
going for it is the Google assistant
this is the first phone that has the
assistant baked-in that has all of
Google personalized just for you so
every time you long press the home
button
the assistant pops up and you can talk
to it what time is it in Bangkok
anything you want this is everything
that Google has there Google now is
built-in here to put the Google
assistant is really the center of this
phone and it's really the thing that
Google is hoping will differentiate it
from the iPhone it built a phone that
looks a little bit like the iPhone
although it has no camera hump and it
does have a headphone jack so that's
good
but in general this is meant to be a
straight forwardly excellent high spec
high-end phone plus a little bit of
Google